what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into heroes in crisis
part three what I want to do here is I
want to kind of switch up how we would
normally record this we're just to say
normally we would go through the way the
books written and kind of call it a day
the issue with this is that the way the
Tom King does this is this literally
like the first page is lagoon boy the
second page is is Wally West the third
page is like Booster Gold and then it
goes back to lagoon boy then it goes
back to Hualien and goes back to Booster
Gold and so what it does is it would
create all kinds of weird issues when
we're trying to record this and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna split it
into segments because really it focuses
on these three characters on wall-e
booster and an Lagoon boy and the first
person I want to focus on here is the
segment about lagoon boys character now
as he's going through here he's
basically being shot with a laser
consistently but remember the nature of
of sanctuary is that it's designed to be
a place of healing a place for people to
kind of move on past whatever struggles
they have and then go back to being a
hero you know it's kind of like a rehab
clinic to a degree but more more like a
trauma clinic now the important thing
about this is that with lagoon boys
seeking this out on himself initially we
didn't really know why this was
happening but then Tom keen goes through
and kind of gives us an explanation
about lagoon boy and actually draws on
on former instances of his character and
so the sort of uh to sort of wind the
clock back a little bit you know what
Lagoon boy tells us here is that as he's
as he's doing this what he's doing is
hearing the screams of various members
of the Titans that he had fought
alongside and who were severely injured
in in a variety of different ways you
know for example one of the characters
power boy was injured he hears you know
he hears his screams in his mind he
hears the screams of like a care to name
Barda what this does is it kind of goes
back to the to the origin of Lagoon boy
and then the attempts of DC to like
branch off the team Titans title wine
o'clock back to 1998 there was a guy
named Erik Larsen who took over the
Aquaman series now Erik Larson's Aquaman
run I was written after Peter David and
a lot of Aquaman fans hated the Erik
Larson run but in reality it wasn't
really Erik Larson's fault Riley here
was more of like an editorial mandate
which is to say that under Peter David
the writing of Aquaman was was pretty
dark and it was pretty heavy-handed and
so coming out of that it was make
Aquaman lighter and the result was that
in a lot of ways the run of Erik Larson
came off as kind of campy now Lagoon
blur was introduced in issue number 50
and the idea was to form a group that
was called the the surface lovers I
think it was what it was called um but
basically it was it was lagoon boy and a
couple of the people who essentially
took to kind of like going against
Atlantean ways and then just kind of
being more of like a bridge kind of
serving the roles
they're kinda like a bridge between the
surface world in Atlantis of course
didn't take to all of the Atlantean
people but for lagoon boy himself he
actually has no origin in DC Comics as
far as I'm aware he was just there one
day and the reason why no origin was
given if I were a betting man I would
say it's because you know the run of
Eric Larsen wasn't very well received
which means that Lagoon boy was not very
well received now that goes into the
teen titans special which I want to say
was written by Chuck Dixon although I
could be wrong but it was Teen Titans
East and Teen Titans East was designed
to take the normal Teen Titans team and
then create like a secondary team that
would basically function in a different
capacity but would still follow the Teen
Titans brand would still have team you
know th superheroes but basically you
had this this New Teen Titans team that
was formed and then like right off the
bat they go against the kids a trigun
who basically wrecked them all and
that's the experience that Lagoon boys
talking about when he talked about
hearing their screams and different
things like that being shot with a laser
you know and so on and so forth that's
what he's enduring here he's constantly
doing it to himself and the reason why
is because with a laser passed to him
and put him in a comatose state so on
and so forth his idea is if he endures
being shot enough times eventually it
won't affect him anymore and so the
screams will stop in his head that's the
kind of treatment he's going with here
now that's the important thing about
sanctuary its sanctuary does not really
seem to have any true doctors which is
to say it's not as where they go in
there and then they're diagnosed and
then they say here's what you need to do
to fix your problem instead they go in
there and it is kind of left to their
own devices and they stay however long
they need to stay until that trauma is
essentially remedied which as you guys
can imagine can cause all kinds of
different problems and that's what
Lagoon boy indoors is constantly being
shot with lasers now of course there
comes a point where somebody says stop
I'll come back tomorrow and we'll
continue the process again but that's
basically what he's doing is literally
injuring himself under the idea that
eventually he'll become immune to it or
it won't face him anymore I won't bother
him anymore and the belief is that when
that time comes he won't have to worry
about the voices in his head or anything
like that now switching over to wally
west things are a lot more
straightforward here one of the things
to bear in mind when it comes to to
classic wally west is that he's been
stuck in the speedforce all this time
when the events of new 52 happened and
everything was rebooted and classic
wally west was nowhere to be found when
rebirth started DC answered the question
of where's classic Wally West Bend by
saying he's been stuck in the Speed
Force and Barry Allen was finally able
to bring him out by remembering him and
so ever since then classic Wally has
been getting his memories back slowly
and steadily and that means he's been
learning about his children giant iris
he's been learning about Linda Park the
fact that they were married but
that's not the case now you know by
whatever manner and whatever means
presumably do the actions of dr.
Manhattan everything Wally West knows
has been changed and so where you can't
just run to Linda Park and say hey we're
married and we have kids and expect her
to kind of be on board like oh that
makes sense if that's not gonna happen
and so what he's been doing here is
basically trying to like figure out or
at least try to find somebody to kind of
cope with his existing environment and
so what we end up finding out is that
what he's been doing is basically
recreating his life inside of sanctuary
where he has Linda Park who runs out to
greet him where he has his kids giant
iris he has the life he always wanted
and so one of the cool things is that he
and his kids the tornado twins actually
end up facing off against Captain cold
and that's kind of like reliving the
memories reliving the way things used to
be now in reality this is a good way of
coping with things but I feel like what
Tom King is hitting out here is that
this can be a very very dangerous thing
and the reason why is because there is
such a thing as getting lost in any
scenario that we're in there's only ever
two circumstances that we face the
reality as things are and the way we
would like them to be and oftentimes if
we allow ourselves to get stuck in the
way that we would like them to be we get
trapped there we never fully recover
like we never come back from there right
because I mean like why would you it's
like Star Trek to Star Trek generations
right well the movie was terrible they
had this really really cool concept
called the ribbon and basically if it
passed over you you were yanked into a
place called the Nexus and you
essentially repeated the best moments of
your life presumably for all eternity or
at least for however long your body held
out but if you if you were given the
opportunity to relive the best moments
of your life why wouldn't you take that
opportunity and if you were given that
opportunity and you did take it what's
to say you wouldn't get lost and that's
the issue with Wally West here Wally
West is living in a life that doesn't
exist anymore and living in this life
that doesn't exist anymore he won't want
to leave or at least it seems like he
won't want to leave and so in response
to that how can you yank somebody from
perfection how can you yank somebody
from absolute tried and true happiness
this is the life he always wanted he has
his wife he has his kids he has the
things that he lost that he wants back
so dear but the problem is that he's not
facing the reality of the situation the
reality situation is that his his
family's basically gone and maybe it's
one of these things where if it had been
allowed to play out the Tom King would
have written it out in such a way to
where Wally West would have just been
able to say goodbye I have to let you go
I remember Wally is Wally was told by
Professor zoom you know he was told hey
like your kids are alive like your kids
are alive and they exist out there
somewhere so
is most likely on the hunt for them or
will be on the hunt for them at some
point in time but it's one of the
interesting things because the way this
is written it almost seems to kind of
ignore that idea right like I almost
used to kind of ignore the notion that
while he's aware of his children's true
existence because then the question
would be if he does know they exist why
isn't he out finding them so again you
know these little tidbits are kind of
you know a little bit of a little bit of
conflict going on there but nothing
outrageous you know it's just kind of
wall-e living this life that ultimately
it doesn't seem like you'll want to let
go up now for Booster Gold his segment
of the story is a lot more
straightforward he's a guy trying to
figure out what in the heck is going on
but here's the issue with this so
Booster Gold has always had two parts to
himself right like there's the Booster
Gold as the hero and the Booster Gold
who's a liar the Booster Gold from like
as he exists like he's basically a con
men right like you took technology from
the future travel to the past and is
like I'm the greatest hero in the future
and it just kind of purported that idea
in the present day the issue with that
is that boosters been living without lie
the entire time that's that's kind of
the thing like like what he goes through
we kind of get this explanation of
what's going on with regards to the
nature of of sanctuary in the sense that
when this issue first opened up and
Booster Gold first arrived at sanctuary
he was met by basically what appeared to
be Montauk hint in Lana Lang now the
inclusion of them is not accidental
sanctuary itself was built using the
technology of Superman the ingenuity of
Batman and the hope of Wonder Woman but
when it comes to the character of MA and
POC hint in Lana Lang they hold a very
particular place in DC Comics not just
with Superman but with DC Comics as a
whole and what I mean by that is that is
that Jonathan and Martha can't kind of
represent the greater wisdom that people
kind of impose these pearls of wisdom on
us that was the nature of ma of Jonathan
and Martha Kent helping Superman become
more than just a guy with powers and
become something that represented hope
for Humanity Lana Lang plays a very
important role because she was the first
person to recognize her to learn the
powers of Superman and taught him how to
use them so she was very much kind of
like a younger guiding hand for Clark
Kent as opposed to the the pearls of
wisdom that were instilled on him twice
on Ethan and Martha Kent but with the
nature of sanctuary itself what it does
is it basically changes your environment
using Kryptonian crystals and that
allows you to use whatever you need to
do in order to get past things for
Booster Gold he's facing himself that
Booster himself has a lot of unresolved
issues here now these aren't really
delved into too far in this you know
it's just kind of like hey basically
everything you do screws up why well
because you're not doing it for good
reasons you're doing it because you're
trying to prove that you're an actual
hero and
that's the nature of booster and those
are the two diets those two
diametrically opposed views that his
character represents on one half you
have Booster Gold who wants to be the
hero and on the other half you have
Booster Gold doing everything to show
he's a hero when in reality he's not
he's a conman he doesn't think like a
good guy he thinks like how can I prove
that I'm a hero by doing this he's
basically trying to fix what's not
broken and so what that does is it
creates all kinds of problems for his
character now before any of this goes on
before we really get any HBO huge
explanation on what's happening with
these guys suddenly alarms start going
off and when they do lagoon boys killed
he's one of the people that's killed
Wally races out only to find that of
course red arrow Arsenal whatever you
want to call him Roy Harper is basically
dead and the person over looking at all
is Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn tracks
Wally West over the head without with a
mallet and kills Wally West and so as it
it's kind of like okay well then Harley
Quinn of course you know was one who
killed Wally presumably is the one who
seems to have killed everybody else it's
kind of intriguing and it's kind of
interesting because we don't really know
exactly what direction things are going
and it's one of these scenarios were
kind of like vantage point right like
all these things are happening but we're
looking at it from different
perspectives trying to figure out who
the who's ultimately responsible for the
death of all these characters but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explained make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the robb core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later purse
[Music]
you